the Granger
we is disempowered and
that sense the citizenry of We the
People is disempowered when prosecution
becomes professionalized when its
institutionalized and becomes like a
paid government function in in the sense
of organization 1870 in our history the
adoption of a professional structure of
prosecution and that effectively meant
that the grand jury had a staff and that
staff was the prosecution and the staff
eventually takes over the function of
the grand jury to a point where it's no
longer any hedge against state power at
all it's a joke now on the Pettitte jury
side a two-step process it's the judges
on the Pettitte jury side who first took
unto themselves the sovereignty of the
people they assert that the law as they
see it is the sovereign and the jury's
job becomes only to apply the law as
given to them but that is not the
original idea and then they approve the
prosecution and they permit plea
bargaining with the result now that jury
trial is more or less a joke both on the
grand jury side and the Pettitte jury
side